j'ai à bordeaux un art division pauvres
on éteint la lumière
pensez à quoi la baloche maintenant
qu'est-ce qu'on va enfin j'ai pas
compris ce que vous avez fait de ce
programme un ordi view un ordi vinardi
view une forme d'interview s'appelle
l'art d'idiot la dernière chose que vous
faites avant de vous coucher
banalement je lis un livre pour le teint
pressé de me vider l'esprit un peu
voilent accès oui voilà
le matin quand vous regarder dans la
glace vous vous dites quoi fava ouf ça
ça passe sa base ça passe
médiathèque va mal que mon gant c'est
vrai qu'ils changent auriez quoi en vous
si vous aviez une baguette magique ça
bouazzi né mon avis je me bats peut-être
j'aurais aimé bosse au stade les sages
je fais un peu complexe avec ceux avec
les années ça passe ça aussi mais
peut-être plus grands un peu plus vers
les mesurer combien ce un pied c'est
donc un mètre soixante et qui voit de
gallons par jour 1 m 67 68 une fois mais
finitions etc laurent un spécial québec
ouais et on avait pris un traducteur oui
j'en serais riche en simultané non mais
là on comprend très bien avant ce fait
les traductions tout de suite au flop
jean marc mois dans l'oreillette on me
dit 5 gallons de pièces est la phrase me
supporte pas d'entendre québécois cet
accent de merde ce que les femmes
préfèrent chez vous je viens de vous le
dit
na viens de vous le dire a dit les mots
nous sommes allés voir ce qui vous aimez
ce qui nous énerve le plus chez vous qui
m'énerve le plus peut-être mans je
t'encule c'est simple ses fans ça c'est
moche annales avec les années j'essaie
de le contrôler
tu contrôles bien l'impulsivité la cool
si vous aviez le choix jaune il désire
il faut préserver et faire l'amour avec
une fille très moche ouais mec très beau
h m a dit qu il a répondu lui ah oui à
lui c'est un mec très beau tout de suite
pas du tout ni l'un ni l'autre
l'appelant pourquoi je partirais sur une
île déserte sérieux alors bas je pense
que non je pense que je vais rester tout
seul on n'a pas le choix ça on n'a pas
le choix
quoi qu'est ce que vous feriez si vous
restez 24 heures à vivre
j'étais à faire votre vie vous
changeriez quoi c'est rien du tout non
mais vous vous changez lecuona pourquoi
il dit ça ouais parce qu'ils sont nés
ils ont vécu dans des pays libres
moi j'aurais voulu être chanteuse
danseuse dans un cabaret libre
mais ça c'était vraiment les choses
interdites chez nous absolument a de
quoi se situerait à refaire ma vie c'est
ce que je serai les milliardaires elle
veut faire strip tease où c'est beau la
lumière